did you see the 2016 jokes yeah so is
that justification to get
slapped no but seven years later no not
at all but if it is true what y'all were
saying did there was a conversation
between will what that's not verified
would it this whole story somebody made
making that [ __ ] up on twitter it's one
person said on twitter so you don't know
if it's real or not yeah if it's real
that's a different thing i tend to
believe it's not because again chris
rock is aware of how thin he is
the [ __ ] swimming for exercise
you know i mean like he know he ain't
fighting yeah trying to fight a guy who
played ali and dove was saying that
chris rock has had a broken arm and that
he's been like in a cast or in a slang
for the last few months
so it's possible
that the arm ain't even working he just
took off the sling or whatever so he
could deliver the jokes now i don't know
if will smith knows this but if he does
he's double [ __ ] yeah because he knows
that chris ain't gonna come back yeah i
don't think will knows that either to be
fair but it's still a [ __ ] movie i mean
chris rock got to smash jada oh my gosh
yeah 100
jada would do it yeah oh my gosh
yeah you take home the golden globe
are you talking about her he hit his
head
you got to smash the mother
oh
because she's the first vampire like you
take her out and then all the others
normally go to will be like call me
daddy
yeah
actually is it is it crazy that they let
him stay there it's [ __ ] insane that
i couldn't believe it that's insane okay
i couldn't believe that's where you call
out hollywood you do that [ __ ] you do
that [ __ ] oh we gonna talk about
hollywood because
uh these all these [ __ ] care
about is their stupid [ __ ] awards and
nothing else matters outside i mean they
gave roman polanski an absentee award
this is the guy who's a legit pedophile
convicted yeah living in france where
you could do that gave him an award half
the people stood up clapping
[ __ ] crazy these guys but the movie
was fire pieces of [ __ ] shut up there's
a
is
yeah so all right the point is
he gets uh he doesn't get kicked out i
mean you do this in a basketball game
you're kicked out you're suspended
you're literally anywhere anyway you're
kicked out you don't get kicked out
there because we all know that they know
he's going to win yes right and they
don't want to [ __ ] up the live show and
they don't want to make a scene yes and
they don't want it to be bad i was
assuming he would get kicked out and
then they would give the award to
somebody else 100 they just
our [ __ ] presenter son it's crazy you
ask this guy to come here and present an
award and then he gets attacked and then
the guy
sits there and gets a [ __ ] award at
the end of that and people are going
nuts for him
this fell crazy dog and what's crazy is
that he wasn't one of the hosts
will smith was nominated for the oscar
he had the power before the award to say
i'm not showing up if chris rock is
performing and roasting or you hit chris
and go yo if you say some [ __ ] about my
girl i'm gonna beat the [ __ ] at you yeah
beforehand simple as that like do you
think he knows you said it to him
already he's assuming that if that's
true if that's we're assuming some
random tweets are true sure that's not
verified in any way shape or form but
it's safe to assume that he probably
didn't like that he was making fun of
his girl at the 2016 [ __ ] yeah but i
also don't know if will said anything yo
so who's the kind of guy that likes his
wife [ __ ] somebody else and stay with
her but he should have the question on
twitter seems to be why is will smith so
upset about a joke about his wife go on
and not um his wife hooking up with
other guys
that should be the thing that makes you
more upset and i think tom segura even
said it like we know who you really want
to slap but you can't slap that person
so you're slapping the people that are
talking [ __ ] yeah i don't know we don't
know what's goes on in their private
house i think they have an open uh uh
open marriage it's pretty clear people
have people know
girls will has [ __ ]
and the fact that the public knows that
i think he's probably [ __ ] ten times
more so then why does he slap chris rock
because he's that protective of his wife
fed up he's been he's been dying
he's been the punching bag for the past
three years why is he the punching bag
if it's an open marriage
no because can he talk about how open he
is
he's i think i think honestly he's doing
that to protect his wife
that's what we're saying everything is
to protect his wife and his wife ain't
protecting him his wife is out there
like yeah we had an entanglement yeah
this she wasn't even yo when you watch
that she wasn't even remorseful once
she wasn't even remorseful like she was
almost angry when he brought it up when
he says entanglement and he questions
the words she gets irritated yeah that's
what i said entanglement like [ __ ] you
cheated bro no it's nothing wrong even
if it wasn't cheating you know i look
stupid yeah and you out here angry that
i brought up that you [ __ ] up we
supposed to keep this on the low you
couldn't control and keep it alone and i
look stupid and you angry at me i'm the
one getting embarrassed and then i call
you out on wording and you get yeah
that's what i said no it's not what
you're saying i agree with you guys she
could be a witch bro
i agree with you
there's only one way yeah you know what
take that i've never seen them on the
island this is a bit of a cookie take
but it's out there that he is in an
emotionally abusive relationship and
that's why he cares so much about what
she thinks okay and her reaction is
something oh gosh can i ask you a
question yeah
please
would an emotionally abusive person date
someone who's like 25 years younger than
them get into a relationship with that's
a good point like well he's not like
getting out of he's not like a drug
addict or anything yeah like with that
emotionally abusive person do that
maybe you may be yeah controlling
emotionally abusive person might get in
relationships with someone fresh off a
drug habit there's needing
you think maybe they would do that of
course she's emotionally abusive bro
okay so i don't understand how that's
not coming up more
and it's all will the the fact that he's
being celebrated for this is [ __ ]
mind who's being celebrated dude it is
50 50. will is being celebrated
yeah yeah you talk about my wife yeah it
then it's a lot of the same people
nobody talking about your wife because
your wife keep her mouth shut
now i'm saying like it's very simple
like all of us got girls we got wives we
are choosing not to make them public
figures yeah they are choosing not to
make our lives public yes maybe you get
little shots of our life but it's not
every little [ __ ] bit of trials and
tribulations that we go through they
want that context matters your wife is
not his wife you want to talk about
alopecia about your struggle with
alopecia and how you getting over and
all that stuff but then you don't want
the world to also talk about it yeah
that's you don't have to worry about it
but nobody else can it's a disorder what
does that mean
you [ __ ] we talk about you yeah yeah
but i could take it and it's like i
told you guys that because i know the
jokes are gonna come but it's like if
you are just because she's talking about
her she's monetizing it she's not just
talking about she's monetizing it saying
on the thing she gets paid on i just
have to laugh at it that's done i'm
gonna watch that and say the [ __ ] could
take a joke then i don't know i still
not the okay to make fun of a disorder
yeah it was 100 and one that probably
affects her every day he also didn't say
like i ha i have alopecia but
it was from stress and sleep when i
wasn't sleeping at all and i had [ __ ]
crop circles in my [ __ ] head
that's true i remember that and i had to
[ __ ] shave and just do fine
hairstyles where i can hide it and just
like that [ __ ] was annoying to deal with
it was sensitive it was it sucked like
you guys made no
but
that and uh didn't make jokes yeah
well because i'm very sensitive to hair
loss
but i'm just saying i'm saying like men
lose our hair all the time we're
supposed to be sensitive about a girl
doing that's equality i'm just saying
you take shots at everything i do take
shots today so the fact that you didn't
do that
you felt like hey maybe i shouldn't take
a shot that's not it it's because you
were working like 22 hours a day and i
felt bad
that i didn't want you to stop that i
actually exactly worked 22 hours a day
then you had hair yeah
that changes things if i had known you
at alopecia i'd have definitely made fun
of you a lot yeah why did you tell us
i thought his name was short for
alopecia
i really did think that for a long time
it's alex with two x's
i see how things are
[Applause]